welcome to or robed reactions episode 1
what should I react to well I figured
I'd react to some coding videos of some
sort but most of them we're pretty
boring so I don't know if that's gonna
work too well so I'm gonna try to find
something a little more exciting let's
uh let's see what patrick shui learned
from ten years of coding as a software
engineer not as a millionaire this time
this is a new video about look I've been
coding for well over ten years and I've
worked as a ex-google X Facebook tech
lead hold on I'm gonna back up a little
bit and adjust my cam stuff so yeah this
is a new video what I learned from ten
years of coding as a software engineer I
don't have headphones now right now so I
apologize sounds gonna be a little
messed up but what let's have a watch
and I'll give my opinion in this episode
I wanted to teach you some of the most
valuable insights and tips I've learned
as a software engineer during my time
and a lot of these lessons I've learned
over hard struggles long hours debugging
trash code and technical depth or simply
the only with uncooperative and arrogant
the team mates so I wanted to give you
some of the top lessons that I've
learned such why do I have a feeling
that he's the uncooperative and arrogant
teammate him why do I have that feeling
mistakes that I may have made in the
past and this is going to say mistake
number one
I was arrogance take number two was
whatever in over ten years of software
gene quick pause here's my sponsor click
this crap I'm just gonna skip all that
so uh yep that's what he's gonna do
yeah you got sponsors Congrats
mmm okay let's see if this is past the
sponsor engineers we're having a design
technical discussion and yeah not a
single person would have actually looked
at the actual code base everybody maybe
they read the document they read some
internal wiki they read an email and
their hold on hold on I gotta back this
up a little bit he said something
that nobody knows how to code so I could
be the first lesson is that nobody knows
how to code that's actually a decent
assumption even if somebody does know
how to code in some language there's so
many other languages and you can't
expect them to know how to code in all
of them it's just not realistic but
let's hear his point out this room with
30 self-proclaimed software engineers
we're having a design technical
discussion and yet not a single person
would have actually looked at the actual
code base wait a second you're having a
meeting with home I'm gonna make sure I
got this right 30 other software
engineers about design and they haven't
looked at the code yet you don't you
don't look at the code for well it
depends it depends how you're looking at
it but typically when you're designing
something you were gonna just kind of
figure out how you want it to work the
code is very technical you don't look at
that first you look at yeah you look at
the overview first which is avi einat
code so okay I want to say you're wrong
on this point already there mister
way or however you say your name but
everybody maybe they read the document
they read some internal wiki they read
an email and they're they're ready to
discuss something but nobody actually
looked at the real code and if you think
about it most you would think some of
them would have browsed the code what
makes you think they didn't look at the
code did you go ask every single one of
them are you just saying this for your
video you just need a point for your
video is that what this is I'm gonna
turn on mother light look so much like
Jekyll and Hyde here all right most
people in the team has never seen the
code the engineering manager has no clue
what the code wait I thought you said 30
software engineers
now you're talking about non software
engineers with 30 self-proclaimed
software engineers 30 self-proclaimed Oh
engineers but later they're not even
engineers they're just another job
titles I'm friggin confused by this
first point
they're so preoccupied
Google features and on the side they're
playing ping-pong surfing reddit and
watching that flicks that in the end
very few people are actually looking at
the codebase most other people on a
second does this seriously have a
positive like to dislike ratio ratio how
is that possible how's this pop company
they're either posing positioning
themselves strategically getting into
personal branding you guys wait look
there are interviews there are technical
interviews people that get into
positions should be qualified if they're
Knights their managers I don't know I
don't want to get into it anymore just
he's just obviously speaking total BS
right here to get to give you time and
it's working Here I am viewing it some
people writing a bunch of emails
responding to emails right there a bunch
of documentation coming up with wiki
pages talking with other people
strategizing the most valuable software
engineer is the person who's turning out
the most code who you could go and rely
on who you couldn't ask about how to get
feature done or what the time estimate
for a project is and then well everybody
else in the company they're just pretty
a bunch of noise around you tried okay
so I think maybe he's working off the
theory that in a company 20% of the
people do 80% of the work theory where
most people are generally useless but
there's a couple of them probably the
ones that turn out the most code that
are actually doing useful stuff but
that's not you know that's all
situational you don't know that just
because somebody doesn't churn out a
bunch of code doesn't mean they're
useless or whatever he's trying to say
his point seems very convoluted and he's
just looking for view time to be useful
they're trying to come and say hey can I
help design the button for you doing
your button do you need don't need to
button get out of here with your buttons
me to manage you didn't need me to
unblock you what can I do to pretend
that I'm useful here that's really what
most other people are doing you need me
to help you you need to unblock you okay
so it is kind of true that when you get
into an organization you have access to
certain things and there's a reason for
that they don't want someone that on day
one to have access to everything in the
company and then just
downloaded to their personal drive or
whatever and then quit and say oh I got
all your company secrets yeah they don't
do that and you slowly get access to the
things you need generally in a company
and the reason isn't for the upper
management to waste time it's generally
to protect protect the business and if
you you know if someone steals all your
stuff anyway yeah that could that could
really well who knows it's just
obviously an illegal thing so there's a
reason that not everybody has access to
everything
they can't even code and they need to
wait software engineers can't code why
are they getting hired into software
engineer positions I don't I don't quite
understand pair program with you so that
you do most of the work for them a lot
of people are just going around faking
and pretending now it is also no secret
that coding is pretty hard and when you
get into a new organization you have to
figure out their style and what is
acceptable for their codebase and all
that and that varies a lot so sometimes
it takes a new guy some time and it
makes it helps a lot to be able to see
someone more senior and that pushes code
all the time kind of see their process
and see okay what do I need to change
from my process to to kind of get up to
par you know there's there's stuff like
that and that's totally understandable
where we just what are we doing tech
leader we're just not supposed to learn
no learning allowed you just kind of
have to know it you have to you have to
be a millionare software engineer only
that's that's the only way you're valid
at all is is that what's going on here
I'm just really confused by this video I
was expecting to get some info but all
I'm getting is trash can all right let's
keep going I think that they're trying
to do something and it's like if you can
just manage to sit down for a few hours
and just just take a quick look at the
code instead of chatting with your
co-workers going on reddit surfing
Facebook going across the street for a
espresso going down to lunch for a
full-course me okra is I don't
understand I'm still most people work
40-hour work weeks yeah you got like an
hour for lunch that's typically unpaid
so there's some some time and most your
time at work yeah you're probably gonna
be working on stuff you might waste a
little time here and there sure but he's
saying like people waste all 40 hours of
their work week all the time and maybe
some do but that's not something I'm
used to when I'm at a job I typically
try to get the job done so I can go home
on time and stuff like that you know I
don't it depends what the job is some of
them you leave on time no matter what
maybe it's easier to slack off on those
but a lot of jobs I've done I like
having goal-oriented jobs where I can
work towards a goal and I need to get
that goal done maybe they don't have
that at Facebook or wherever he came
from grab me an ice cream on their way
back checking your email checking her
Facebook again responding into the email
checking your Facebook you get like if
you can just stop without this
distraction and just take a look at the
code it's going to put you miles ahead
there are often okay so new revelation
here from tech lead not wasting time
we'll put you miles ahead yeah we
already knew that schedule random
meetings for you with a no agenda just
to waste your time and I just want to
throw a pity party for themselves and
worry and cause a bunch of anxiety and
debate and think about this and you
wonder how do you know there's so many
presumptions in this in this situation
that are actually unknowns like so wait
let's let's hot hypothetically say a
co-worker send you a medium request and
it's got to have something it can't just
be untitled right or you're gonna ask
what's this meeting for so they need to
have something and maybe they just want
to ask you a few questions and that's
fine why wouldn't you answer questions
for someone someone else you work with
after all how do you expect them to be
productive if you won't answer their
questions or you won't teach them how to
do any of the business critical stuff
that's kind of an inside secret you know
you have to teach new people I think
what Patrick is going into here is he's
saying everybody should already know
anything and I shouldn't ever have to
teach everyone I'm a
soldier in this organization or whatever
it's that's what I'm hearing from him so
he sounds like an absolute nightmare to
work with
can't imagine this guy being my boss I'd
probably quit pretty quick usually I try
to end things on good terms if I have to
but I could see I could see myself
giving Patrick the finger on the way out
you could spend weeks really on an email
going back and forth when in reality the
answer was just a one-liner in code and
the funny thing is sometimes I'll see
software engineers pray on these
anxieties like they'll say that the
abstract virtual factory manager is
uncapable of integrating with some mixin
Factory due to the Q class not really
supporting offline networks and then
everybody was there whoa whoa that
sounds crazy that sounds pretty hard so
how that sounds crazy as it sounds
pretty hard I would just say to that
person that said that I have no idea
what that means
that's what I would say to him like in
in a meeting if someone said that thing
to me I would just look at them maybe
look around the room and look back at
them and say I have no idea what that
means and they might try to play the
card over oh you know that when people
do stuff like that they're always like
I'm they're trying to make themselves
look higher or bigger than you and
whatever it is and you can just you can
just call them out because I guarantee
you nobody else understand that either
so why are you all listening to them
it's like this mob mentality has gone
way too far
jeez does anybody have any common sense
anymore Patrick have we seen you and the
riots have you been out there breaking
windows are you are you going with this
- give me two days and I'll give you an
estimate and really if you are a good
software engineer then you're going to
make it easy for other people instead of
giving them all of the crazy little
technical details that really nobody
cares about or there we go
yeah if you're a good engineer you will
make it easier for other people that's
probably the first good thing or
intelligent thing he said in this video
just tell them give them a timeline
right just tell them I'll get this done
in two days and then when two days comes
make sure you deliver on that and you
don't really need to go into the weeds
about all the crazy details because at
the end of the day nobody cares about
any of that code code this garbage
alright moving on what you're
contradicting yourself a lot okay so on
the first point you were mad
not everybody cuz nobody looked at the
code at all and on the second point is a
he you said no you don't need the
details the fine details don't matter
you nobody needs to know anyway don't
look at the code what those are
contradicting things the second lesson
for software engineers is that designers
designers are the problem generally what
you find
designers are the problem are this is
gonna be good let's hear let's hear how
your crappy logic for engineers are
building a bunch of random one-off
features and code to support a bunch of
it was building a bunch of one-off
random features in code
I don't companies don't normally do that
I don't know where you came from where
they do that Facebook is that what's
happening at Facebook I'm guessing all
over the app and it's like this page has
that button designed in one way and he's
talking about pages okay so most of
these software engineers on YouTube are
not really software engineers are
usually just web programmers which you
know you can call software engineer
because you're engineering software and
stuff but I guess what I'm saying maybe
I'm saying this completely wrong I don't
really consider being a a web specialist
a computer scientist I'm more in the
computer scientist realm of things so I
don't know where I'm really going with
this other than I feel like he's miss
saying something here
let's continue then another page has a
button that flashes and animates and
then another page has a pop-up dialog
and then there's another pop-up dialog
that animates and bursts open and then
you have another pop-up dialog in the
menu and then you find inconsistencies
throughout the whole entire project
multiple ways to build multiple
different types of buttons fonts layouts
tags that just look different from one
another and people are building things
over and over again because each time
the designer wants something a little
bit different and so I tend to believe
that you should not be building features
you should be building a system you
build it well I think this is kind of a
good point like yeah if you build a
bunch of individual features it gets
kind of clunky most stuff most most
applications are built around tool set
so you're often building tool sets and
stuff like that to build further of what
you want I think that's pretty common
and maybe that's what he's getting
saying here I kind of agree with that
point in our design system that can
support any number of features and what
then when you build a generic design
system you're kind of building some form
of like an engine or something or you're
redesigning view or something I don't
know view Jas and then the problem is
when some artsy designer comes in and
they really have no rational logical
thought it's just like whatever looks
good and there's no consistency or
design language or system or process in
anything that they do so what what do
you mean none pretty sure that last
statement isn't even possible being true
it's just like 100 percent false say
they want a button and stop using the
pre-built button that you already have
they say that they want this button to
be one pixel off it's like okay then you
have to create a whole new button for
this and then the next designer wants a
button that's a little bit different
shade in color and so you have three
buttons now and then it just explodes
the code base into thousands of files
and you have to hire thousands of
engineers just to support each different
design that a designer has is that just
coming up with the consistency of say 10
different designs not that they're less
than I have here is that I don't really
fully understand that point I think
you're just saying make tools to make
stuff rather than making stuff I guess
that's the point sometimes that
sometimes that makes sense other times I
don't know and so many software
engineers they think that they're so
smart because they're the only technical
person within their smaller group of
friends or their family and they're the
computer guy and you know what the fact
is get off your high horse stop trying
to be so smart people look I don't know
if that's true or not you know what
really works in the software system is
not cleverness but consistency
consistency can really improve the
readability of code your ability to
quickly navigate through huge swaths of
files and so imagine that you have a
software system with horn wow this is a
really scattered point so it went from
technical people are like really
conceited and on some kind of high horse
too
right consistent code that was how that
Segway I don't get it what what what
does that have to do with it I don't I
don't understand tech lien but a
thousand files and all of them are named
something different like yeah wait and
what I'm still trying to figure out what
he's even saying like so if is he saying
that if you're on your high horse and
conceited because you're a good tech or
think you're a good tech then you're
gonna you're not gonna write consistent
code why why would that be the case
how do those even though how do those
relate at all why are those related I
don't get it we have an abstract factory
abstract abstract factory mix in
abstract adapter controller view view
data queue object a queue queue object
controller manager controller manager
factory this guy is like the George
Carlin of coding he just says a bunch of
BS until everybody laughs virtual
abstract factory class mixin when you
have all of these random objects and
data is flowing all over the place you
have to learn how does this whole thing
fit together like a thousand piece
jigsaw puzzle where as compare that to
what if I told you that all of these
thousand files their name the one
they're three things they're either a
Model View or controller right like MVC
architecture then you know yeah maybe
that's not going to be the most optimum
way or is cleverest way to write it but
it makes it extremely simple to quickly
parse the files and figure out what's
going on right you he's got a good point
here take a look it does make sense to
have a I I agree at least here it does
make sense to have your code organized
in a way that newcomers especially
newcomers can understand and work on
things without worrying about breaking
things so he's basically just saying
don't spaghetti your code too much
follow a structure and yeah that's
that's fine I still don't understand how
that goes with technical people are
generally in a small circle where
they're the only technical person and
think they're the bad way where did that
come from I don't understand oh that's
the object that's just gonna be data you
got a few object and that's only for
display or you have controller and
that's just for business logic and then
next time you see a bug and say layout
you know exactly where that is going to
be that's going to be in one of the view
files if there's an issue with business
logic that's going to be in the
controller and then next time that comes
time to refactor everything like let's
say you want to add dark mode support
for instance then you know you just need
to touch the view objects if you want to
add offline support maybe you just touch
the model object for instance that's the
data and so I would say that consistency
is one of the most important things in
software engineering maybe more
important than even simplicity so if I'm
expecting code to be somewhere but it's
not there then that's going to throw me
off and it's going to take me time to
get my bearings straight and so constant
this is a good point the I agree yeah if
you're if you think you know where
something should be if it makes sense
for it to be somewhere and it's just not
there and then you have to go find it
elsewhere that's that's yeah that's kind
of obnoxious but like it's hard to find
a perfect way of doing that yeah I think
one of the I don't know one of my
favorite things to do on a new code
bases is use a lot of grep in recursive
searching especially for keywords unless
they're using some form of editor where
you can search everything in the code
base stuff like that can help a lot but
yeah organizations pretty big design
having your design thought out
beforehand is pretty big I would agree
with those assistants he helps with
readability for not just yourself but
for the entire team such that anybody
can quickly grasp what's going on
without necessarily even using the code
very deeply because as I mentioned the
fact is nobody really reads code and so
consistency nobody really reads code I I
do I step through it and try to analyze
every little thing when I'm reading code
but wait a minute I don't know man I
feel like you know some people read code
you can't just say nobody reads code
does that mean he doesn't read code is
he just like self reflecting here and
like I'm not gonna read your code
because all code is garbage however
organized in this specific way
and it's I'm still not gonna look at it
anyway so what's the matter
no she's also one reason that I
recommend against splitting your text
stack for example if you're doing the
iOS code sometimes you will be writing
the objective-c and then another person
randomly comes in and they won't start
writing in Swift and then someone wants
to bring in react native or someone
wants to bring in flutter and then
you've got four different text acts
maybe someone brings in web views and
everybody is writing code in a different
way and there's multiple ways of
implementing the same features and so
the problem is we go to debug something
or to add a feature you don't even know
where to begin because you may be
expecting an MVC architecture but using
rack native so then you start to get
into the react native code to figure out
how they implemented it and turns out
hey that code was actually jsj SJS SJS
is everyone on YouTube just a j/s
programmer is that is that the only
language you know is JSE stop with the J
as I don't care about J s this is my
personal thing I I'm I'm so annoyed when
I find a new coder or I don't know when
I oh okay I guess I'll say I'm always
annoyed when I find a new video that I
think is gonna be really insightful
about code and all their examples are
just like J s web programming reasons it
just makes me cringe so much and like No
show me something real is what really
sets apart senior engineers from junior
engineers is that like you just have to
stop screwing around I mean essentially
that's it like senior engineers execute
and with junior engineers they're just
so unreliable you pass them a project
you expect them together down two weeks
later they haven't done anything with it
and why okay let's unpack that a little
bit
I think he's mostly right though okay so
ya be a senior engineer you got to get
stuff done you got to deliver sure
that's what that's how you get to those
positions and yeah I feel like if a
junior engineer did absolutely nothing
on a project they're given for two weeks
especially if it's their only project
they probably gonna get fired to be
honest like why why would they be at the
company at all
wasn't the manager everything look
I'm not really sure why we're paying
yeah you just kind of coming in and
nothing's actually you've pretty
absolutely nothing like zero it's
complete zilch you know it's really hard
to work with zilch
I don't know if that's a thing that
people recognize but zero is a really
hard number to work with you ever had a
relationship with someone and and one of
you just stopped con just stop talking
or something and just when zero contact
you can't work with that person anymore
I'm trying to think of a better example
really but I can think of a few like
random personal ones but nothing that
really helps like I'm trying to think of
something that's to put it into
perspective like okay like I once got a
I can't think of any examples I think
you guys get the point in anyway just
you need something to go off of is the
point if someone gives you nothing
that's usually a sign that it's it's
done you know that a it's not working
out it's not you there's nothing you can
do about it you got to move on
basically so to speak and if that means
you gotta get rid of your new junior dev
because they do zilch is absolutely
nothing a zero delivery you know to
delivered one thing that's at least
something you can you can say well he
didn't do that but of zero that's
nothing that's nothing you just you're
just burning money or donating money to
them to show up basically and that's
that's not how work is or should be
anyways the example I was thinking of
and I guess I'll give it
oh hi I'll keep it somewhat whatever I
just won't say any names
well someone I know was having some
trouble and not getting along so well
and there and someone else kind of out
of the blue once called me and said hey
so and so I was not doing so well it's
you know it's been going on for a long
time
I need you to do something and my
response was okay it's been a month
since I heard from you last I've had no
updates no knowing of this situation
nothing this this is the first I'm
hearing of the situation and you want me
to do something immediately no because
you've given me zero information you're
suddenly at some kind of ultimatum I
have no clue how it built up to this I
need something
you said has been going on for a long
time what's a long time was it going on
a month ago when you talked to me well
no then what's a long time is that two
weeks why didn't you tell me two weeks
ago or the day after I you know there
was a I got nothing to go off of here
you're dead in the water it's on you
so that's that's good point all right
let's continue
you know they've just been reading
documentation than surfing read it all
day long it turns out well it's he must
serve read it a lot he had that on his
mind away
so one thing embossing I'm guessing
given how conceited this guy tends to be
and I'm not saying that to diss him it's
just really obvious everybody knows he's
really conceited and he just makes
sarcastic videos it's kind of all about
him and it's money yada yada that's
that's how his channel is that's not me
being down on him that's just kind of me
explaining his channel and obviously it
works he makes tons of money from this
channel and he gets sponsored and
everything it's nuts so I guess what you
got to be do to be successful is be a
d-bag I can't say it all right well
let's just continue watching I forget
what I was even gonna say anymore except
sort of ragging on this channel is that
they don't get themselves blocked you
give a project to a junior engineer they
can be they're so prideful and they
don't want to ask for help and then
maybe two or three weeks later they're
still [ __ ] around the code by
themselves and they haven't told anybody
anything about what they're doing
whereas yeah that's bad that's real bad
for as much as I'm ragging on tech lead
here I'm I'm also somewhat sarcastically
joking although some of that's laced in
truth obviously you don't mean to tell
that but senior engineers though at
least know like okay they don't want to
spend I guess my point is and I'm not
into the video anymore is uh I don't
personally care what he does in his life
it doesn't effect
it's it's just sometimes I see channels
that are successful and it really blows
my mind so but he keeps going and keeps
doing it really shows you that being
consistent keeping making videos will
eventually get you to a better place on
YouTube I guess so that's kind of what
I'm trying to do hopefully I'm not
making totally garbage content more than
a day or two on something they have high
communication and they'll go talk to the
people that they need to in order to
unblock a project and ensure its success
moving on my next lesson is that for
software engineers working in teams the
silent treatment in which you just
ignore other people and you don't tell
them what's going on it doesn't really
work no crap what we've been waiting for
this revelation thanks for telling us
thanks for letting us know that no given
us no information is is uh not helpful
yeah I guess I kind of just weren't in
the same thing so bite my own foot by
making fun of him for it it may work in
relationships they may work in
relationships it may not work in
relationships too after all you did get
divorced in general over communicating
as necessary for high-performing
software engineers over communicating I
like that way of putting it yeah over
communicating is good one thing is that
as I mentioned since nobody has a clue
about what you're doing if you give the
time estimate then you need to hold
yourself accountable to that yes if you
know you're gonna slip then give people
proper for warn me about that yes if
other people say things that they're
gonna do at the end of the meeting send
out some brief meeting notes so that you
hold other people accountable in order
to ensure your own project success yeah
okay that's that's pretty common human
decency here
be honest be transparent that's that's
that's what everybody looks for in a
co-worker you know someone that's
actually honest and transparent
it's very rare though very rare so you
can manage to be both honest and
transparent you can probably get any job
in the world as well otherwise you know
good luck though I don't even know how
to do that honestly I have such a
freakin hard time sharing anything that
it's ridiculous and it makes me mad I I
don't know how to I don't know how to be
transparent you betray
parent okay well you know big stuff I'll
mention but when it comes to my
day-to-day life and like I don't know
I'm just working on my own personal
projects do I need to update people
about that no not really so that's
that's where I struggle but if I'm
working on something with somebody I'm
pretty good at letting them know well
every little thing but usually what
happens is well almost all the time what
happens is it becomes just me because no
one can seem to keep up with me and I
know that sounds like a brag but
actually it's really really really
frustrating it's the opposite of a brag
it sucks I pretty much I'm always stuck
working alone because whatever I'm
working on it's I can't I can't find
anybody else that understands it or that
is willing to dig in where I am so
that's kind of one of the reasons I'm
reaching out over the Internet my my my
little circle of friends is a none of
them are really coders so and the few
that are mostly have moved away now
since college and stuff so and it's very
hard to find people that are deeply
involved in the same little niche
hobbies and stuff you are unless you're
at a job where that's what you're doing
and that's what you're all hired for
then it's easy because you're both on
the same page and you both love it well
ideally you love it maybe maybe you
don't I don't know so I think he's got a
good point here well people are lazy
they're not gonna do what they say
they're gonna do and then you're gonna
be on the hook for that when your
project starts to slip yeah I guess
that's another good point yeah if people
[Music]
cheese I could really go into that
pretty hard actually but I think I'm
gonna refrain similarly if you're
submitting code for a review then
instead of just giving this huge swath
of code which nobody has any idea what's
going on and it takes people by surprise
and then people start delaying your code
because they're checking it and they
don't know what you're up to you know if
you communicate with people and let them
know like this is the feature you're
working on this is how you're gonna do
it you agree with them on the design and
then if you can break down the commits
into smaller chunks that are easy for
people to read because nobody really
wants to read right so you break it down
such that it's really easy for people to
approve that that can help speed up your
work
and so programming is kind of like a
team sport where he seems to have this
mentality where nobody wants to do
anything what kind of people was he
working with if you were working with
people that don't want to do anything
then why are they working there I I get
it on a personal level when you're
asking someone for help and they're not
getting compensated for their time and
stuff but when it's their job why are
they working there if they're not
willing to put the time in isn't that
like zero hours of work zero pay got the
type of thing of there I'm really
confused this seems to be a very common
thing though he's mentioned it multiple
times that most people don't actually do
work while they're at work I'm not used
to that I've seen people waste time at
work but in general they have to get
their jobs done so to say that they
never get anything done is a little
strange
everybody's lazy nobody wants to read
code half the people don't even know how
to read your code people don't want to
be held accountable you use cut people
know how to read your code maybe they're
not taking the time to walk through it
or whatever but you know that's a
different thing it does take a lot of
time he's just using a lot of uh
absolute words you know a lot of nobody
and stuff like that communication it
confuses me I think he actually means
like zero percent of people like if you
take a million people zero then we'll do
it and that's not that's not true and
explicit emails in order to hold people
accountable and make sure that the code
that you submit is as easily
comprehensible to other people as
possible my next tip is that for
software engineers time management it's
actually a huge deal because you know if
you think about it anybody can code
given enough time so what really says
apart good programmers is their ability
to manage time some people will pre
optimize code that needlessly making
sure okay he's got a good point here
optimizing times a tricky thing coding
could take a long time I have a much
different take on this I'm curious to
see what he's gonna say but I'll share
my point after it runs superfast it can
scale up to 100 million users it's like
maybe you didn't need all that speed and
it took to three additional days just to
build in support for that it could take
an extra few months just a good concept
is important support for some of this
stuff I won't make a simple crappy cons
first I think is what he's gonna get
into and then if it's really what you
want that's when you optimize it and
that's that's pretty pretty standard
with software development that every
software developer should know that
common time-suck is refactoring just for
the sake of refactoring because he felt
that the code they didn't look that
clean to you even though yeah we've all
been there it looks pretty clean to
somebody else and you may spend a whole
bunch of time refactoring a piece of
code only to find that the entire
feature is thrown out the next month the
fact is the entire code base will
probably look like trash in just two to
three years so I'm not saying to never a
refactor but to carefully think about
the goal the purpose of that refactor if
you're going to do it yeah I think you
should only refactor if you know for
sure it's gonna make improvements
basically but that's the real way to
save time with coding is to know what
you're gonna code before you code it
right I guess that sounds obvious how do
you write anything if you unless you
know what the right kind of thing but
you you can't just let's say like when
you're writing like a creative story or
something you can kind of make it up as
you go and fill in the holes but with
coding you actually kind of need to know
what you're doing and plan ahead and
design is actually really important for
that I think what he's calling design
and what I'm calling design are two
different things but he's calling design
is like what your buttons look like and
stuff what I'm calling design is how
everything is actually designed to work
together I'm not really talking about
the art so much he's talking he's
calling design art or he's calling art
design I think he's talking about like
how it looks and stuff when I say design
I'm talking about how things interact
with each other
I don't really care what they look like
just as long as it's obvious what it is
it's good enough kind of thing but to
have like the flow worked out like yeah
so you know where you're going I guess
they're both intertwined maybe I maybe
I'm eating my shoe on that one but it's
something like that now a side project
or business is one of the best ways to
get know this as a software engineer
which is why you'll want to check out
scores space.com another ad I'm not
going to do it
maybe one day I'll have some of my own
but right now I am just
a little channel with no ads or anything
I really appreciate your support let me
know what you want me to react to next
here on code Tecna toriel's robed codon
robed reactions let's get to the full
camp yeah Rob reactions so it's been a
lot of fun I'll see you guys in the next
episode stay cool
keep coding and I don't know incircle
word here yeah peace out